hi i'm beau carnes with free code camp
in this course i will teach you how to
create a full ecommerce store with
woocommerce and wordpress these are free
tools that you can use to create a wide
variety of ecommerce websites and i will
teach you everything you need to know
step by step this course is perfect for
beginners there is no coding whatsoever
and you'll be able to do everything with
a simple graphical interface the
woocommerce plugin makes it simple to
turn a wordpress website into a complete
e-commerce business
in this course you will learn how to
customize your store create products
accept payments with credit cards and
paypal set taxes and shipping rates
create coupon codes and more
first i'm going to show you how to do
the initial setup this includes getting
a domain name hosting and installing
wordpress and woocommerce
next i'll show you how to install an
ecommerce store template and easily
customize the look of it so it fits with
your specific brand
after the store looks exactly how you
like i'll show you how to add four
different types of store products
finally i'll show you how to set up the
payment processing automatic tax
calculations shipping rates and coupon
codes so customers can check out on your
website along the way you will also
learn other tips such as customizing the
email sent to customers adding related
products creating store categories and
more
this course is all you need to set up a
store but if you want to learn more
about customizing the look of your
wordpress website you can check out my
previous wordpress course
so let's get started
first i'm going to show you how to get
your domain and your hosting this is the
part that you will have to pay some
money but it is pretty cheap the name
usually costs between 10 and 20 dollars
per year and hosting often costs around
five dollars per month we're going to
use hostinger there's a lot of websites
that provide website hosting hostingers
provided a grant that has made this
course possible and that's why we're
going to show you how to set things up
with hostinger now even before i've made
this course or we got this grant with
free code camp i actually use hostinger
for some of my personal sites and i had
a really good experience with them
some things about hostinger is if you
get the right type of subscription you
can get a free domain lifetime ssl and
ddos protection but just so you know
everything i teach in this course will
work with other hosting providers as
well so you don't have to go with
hostinger so let's just click start down
start now and there's a few different
options here
if you're just starting out i would
recommend just the cheapest option you
can always upgrade later if you need to
but see this includes one website and
then the next one up includes 100
websites but we're just making one
website so just select that one and then
you choose just how long you want to
sign up for
you're probably going to want at least
12 months but you may want the 24 months
or the 48 months to get a different deal
and then you can just enter all your
information now i'm not going to go
through all this right now because i
already have an account but i just want
to show you what you have to do so i
want you to sign into my account and
then i can show you what it's going to
look like after you get signed in
okay once you get signed in you can get
your domain you may have already gotten
your domain in the process of signing up
for your hosting provider but if not you
may have to get your domain afterwards
and just so you know it is possible to
buy your domain from one company and get
your hosting from a different company
and connect them but for this tutorial
we're just showing how you would get
your domain name from the same company
as the hosting so i'll just click claim
domain and here is where you you may
have to search through quite a few
domains to find one that's not already
taken let me just try some
[Music]
how about robot clothing
no
robot attire
okay we got one that worked robot attire
because this is going to be a clothing
store
okay i'm going to claim the domain
let's see i'll get this set up
and this is just on my own personal
and i'll just finish
registration okay now i can start
creating the website
and it's pinning verification so i just
need to go and click the link in my
email and make sure you turn on this
whois privacy or ever anybody can look
up your your information
and you could be getting a lot of email
spam emails and even like letters to
your address
let me show you how to create a custom
email from your domain so i'm on the
hostinger domain overview if i scroll
down here i can go to manage email
here i am going to create a new email
account so i'm going to add email
account
and it's just going to be
info at robot attire.com and then i'll
create a password
and then create
and if i click on webmail it'll open up
to where i can log in
and here once i get logged in i can send
and receive email from info robot
attire.com
okay let me go back to the home here and
i'm going to set up the premium shared
hosting
this is where we'll install wordpress
you can just go through the survey
and here is where you can choose to just
install wordpress or install install
wordpress plus woocommerce
and that's what we want to do we want to
install woocommerce and wordpress
because woocommerce is going to power
the store that runs on wordpress
and then just create an account here
and you can just pick a template right
here i'm actually going to install the
template later just so you can see how
you do if you don't have hostinger if
you're not using hosting or if you're
using a different hosting provider you
may not get a chance to
pick a template right here and you may
have to do it later so that's what we're
going to do
and we'll just connect it right to
robotattire.com
okay i'll finish the setup
and again you can install wordpress even
if you don't have hostinger most of the
popular hosting providers have a way to
install wordpress it just can be
slightly different depending on what
hosting provider you get after the
website is set up you may go right into
the place where you're managing it but
if not you can always go back to the
home page here in hosting or and then
click
manage
now in this page it's going to give you
all the information about your page like
the ip address
and
just like the domain name
and the name servers and also if you're
using a hosting provider that's not
hosting her there's probably a page that
looks kind of like this which is where
you actually install wordpress so you
would probably get into some sort of
managing site just like this and there
will likely be a button somewhere down
here that says install wordpress or says
wordpress or something like that so if
you can't if you don't install wordpress
when you're originally setting up your
page there may be some other way to do
it but once you have installed wordpress
then it's pretty straightforward i'm
going to click on dashboard right here
and then once i get the dashboard i'm
just going to click edit website
we purchased a domain name and hosting
and installed wordpress and woocommerce
now let's customize the store now let me
minimize the page a little bit so you
can actually see the url bar here
now whenever you create any sort of
wordpress website
to get to the admin page where you
actually make all the edits on your
wordpress site it's always the same it's
going to be the url that you previously
chose and it's going to be slash
wp-admin
and then when you get to that you'll log
in now i'm already logged in but if
you're not logged in you'll be able to
log into the admin page and then you can
start making changes on your wordpress
account as soon as we get into here
there'll be some special notifications
it talks about setting up the website
analytics and it says welcome to
wordpress well we can just dismiss that
some of these you can just dismiss now
this one your store does not appear to
be using a secure connection this is
important especially when you're going
to create a store you want it to be over
secure connection it says we highly
recommend serving your entire website
over an https connection now let me show
you how to do that so i'm gonna go back
to the hostinger admin page and look
where it says force https redirect all
websites over acps so i'm going to turn
that on
and then it's going to allow us to
install the ssl certificate now pretty
much all hosting providers are going to
give you this option somewhere but it
could be in a different place so i'm
going to say install ssl
now it says https will be automatically
forced on your domain so instead of http
colon slash last that's http s colon
slash
robot attire.com and the s means secure
so we'll close that
and now i'll just go back over here if i
just refresh this
it's going to have me log in again
because now we're in the secure version
of the website
[Music]
now you can see this lock is here
because we're in the secure version of
the website and if we click this
you'll see connection is secure so we're
in acps which is good and we don't see
that warning anymore over here
okay before we start setting things up
let's see what the website actually
looks like with all the default settings
here so i'm just going to click where it
says i'm going to mouse over where it
says robot attire.com and click visit
site
okay so this is the default
site
i'm going to go back to the admin page
and then on this i'm going to try going
to visit store
okay so this is the default store now
obviously the sign the store don't look
anything like what we want to look like
we're going to be doing a lot of
updating so i'm going to show you how to
edit this site so it looks exactly how
we want to look and now you can see this
top bar here that's because we're logged
into wordpress and just anybody that
goes to your website isn't going to see
this top bar but since we're logged into
wordpress we see that top bar because
we're the administrator so we can do
special things like
edit site customize i'm going to show
you where all these things are later but
if we go back into the url we can see
this is the shop url but we can go back
to the main url just by changing the url
in here so i'm going to show you how to
update all this to be exactly what we
want to look exactly how we want to look
but first let's go back into the
dashboard
before we saw what the website already
looks like and it didn't look that nice
so we are going to install a theme and a
template to just get a basic look for a
site and then we can customize it now a
lot of these things that i'm going to
show you the order doesn't really matter
like we could set up we could do the
woocommerce setup now but we're going to
do that a little bit we are going to
right now go to appearance and let me
just zoom in a little more so it's
easier to see everything anytime you're
using wordpress you're going to use some
sort of theme now it has this 2022 is
the default theme here
but there's tons of different themes
that you can use i'm just going to close
that for now and then i'm going to go to
add new theme so there's a bunch of
really good themes like astra i think
this is one of the most popular themes
out there uh we have ocean wp i showed
how to use this in my previous wordpress
tutorial for this one we're going to use
one called bloxy
now a lot of the themes work well with
ecommerce sites but this one in
particular i found has a lot of good
features for ecommerce sites so i'm just
going to go and install that theme
and then after it's installed i just
click activate
and then i'm going to
install the block c companion it says
right here that it
includes custom extensions demo
templates and minions and many other
awesome features and we're going to be
using one of the the demo templates so
let's install the bloxy companion
okay now if you wanted to if you want to
give them all this extra information you
can but i'm just going to skip there but
if you want to allow and continue you
can and now i'm going to go to starter
sites
so what's cool is it has all these
starter sites that you can install for
free
so we can install one of these starter
sites and then we can go through and
edit it as much as we want so we can use
one of these sites as our base site and
then we can then customize it to make
use our to meet our exact needs so
you're going to want to go through all
these and try to figure out which one
looks most similar to what you want your
website to be well i'm going to just
choose this
garter robe i kind of like that already
focuses on clothing and my site is going
to focus on clothing but you can use any
of these and you can make
like for example see this one's called
petsy you can use petsy even if you're
not going to be
having a website focused on petsy or
focus on pets because once we get this
installed we can do a bunch of edits and
make it
custom for our specific use case so i'm
going to import this one and then we'll
install the child theme also
and then you we can choose which page
builder we want to use there's the
gutenberg page builder and the elementor
page builder now gutenberg is the
default page builder that comes with
wordpress and elementor is is an is an
extra page where like an ad on a special
page builder and most people agree that
elementor is a little easier to use so
if you're a beginner i would recommend
using elementor and i'm going to show
you how to use it later in this course
so just click next here
and it's going to install elementor
woocommerce is already installed and
then it's going to install wp form so
let's click next we'll just import all
the content and install everything
okay starter site imported successfully
so let's view the site
okay so remember what our site looked
like before well now this is what it
looks like so the starter site included
some images
and then it has all these things it even
has some sample products right in here
and i'm going to show you in a little
bit how to update all these how to
change all these things to your products
and your images but it's nice just to
have something to start with that we can
customize for our purposes
and you can see all the text is just
lorem ipsum so it's a sample text that
will will update with our own products
so one thing let's go up here and i'm
just going to click on a product so you
can see what it looks like if we click
on here we can see the product page
and you can see this on sale normally
thirty dollars now it's forty five
dollars
and it even has a review
so users are going to be able to
enter their own reviews for your for
your store when they buy products and
then it shows the top rated products
and then we can even see what happens if
we add this to cart so let's just add
this to the cart i'll view the cart
and then we even have a checkout cart
here
and you can up have coupon codes
then we can proceed to checkout
and even taken billing details
and it says right here sorry it seems
that there are no available payment
methods for your state
we're going to have to set up the
payment methods which i'll show you how
to do and i can't even show you what
it's like to place order until we get
the the payment method right now we have
invalid payment methods because we don't
even we haven't even set up any payment
methods but let's see what else we have
we have the products
and you can see on the main product page
we actually have a filter you can filter
by price
and we can see the different products we
have services
which
will be custom will be specific to your
store and you may not even need this
page depending on what store you're
trying to create you may want to
show what special services your store
offers and then there's the about us
page there's a news page which is
basically a blog
and so we can see all these sample blog
entries here and then a contact page
and you can see how it's always giving
products trying to sell things on every
page
and then we can even search for things
so i'm going to search for a hat
okay that came up with nothing let's try
a watch i saw that there's definitely a
watch in the sample products here
and even comes up right here
okay so people can search for the
products they want
so this is a pretty nice store here so
now let's see how to customize it so
it's specific to your store your
products and what you want it to look
like so let's go back to the dashboard
soon i'm going to show you how to
customize your store and add custom
products but first let's finish this
woocommerce setup so i'm going to click
start selling and it's going to guide us
through some setup things first we're
going to going to put our address if you
look right here it says this is going to
help configure currency options and
shipping rules automatically and this
will not be publicly visible and can be
easily changed later so you don't have
to enter enter this you can set up the
shipping rules and currency
uh
manually but i'm just going to enter
some information here
and then you can choose what are you
going to sell physical products
downloadable products or subscriptions
i'm just going to do physical products
and downloads
and then continue
and then you choose like about how many
products you're going to have
and then they they try to kind of
upsell you it's not it's it's actually
free plug-ins but they try to suggest
what other things you want to add for
now we're not going to add any of those
and
we can always add things later
and then it's going to
ask you if you want to choose theme but
we already did that so let's continue
with the active theme
and we're going to come back to all this
in a little bit the setting up payments
taxes shipping
after we customize our store we're going
to come back and set up all these things
now let's go back to the on the side we
have the woocommerce and we're going to
go to settings
you're probably going to want to update
some of the settings in here
so selling locations where do you want
to sell to
uh this may change depending on what
where you want to ship to like you can
actually type in different
specific countries sell the specific
countries and then you can just
type in type in the countries here like
let's say i'm going to
sell to the united states other canada
[Music]
and mexico
that way i don't have to ship across an
ocean or you can just
choose all countries or whatever
countries you want to sell to and then
shipping locations so
sell the specific coming countries that
means we're selling to people that are
there live in specific countries but you
may not want to ship to the same
locations that you're selling to it's
usually going to be the same that's why
the default is shipped to all countries
you sell to
and the default customer location
where do you think most people are going
to
be now you could do geo locate if you
click geolocate the browser will try to
figure out where the the user is located
and then we'll set the default location
to wherever the browser says they're
currently located so i'm actually just
going to do shop country region so it
will default to the united states where
i'm from and then i am going to enable
tax writing calculations that will set
up more later and able to use a coupon
code you can decide whether you want to
do that
and then you can choose the currency
options so i'll just save changes for
this
now go to the products page
some of the things you're going to want
to choose here are the weight units well
since i'm in the united states i'll
choose pounds but
probably most people are going to choose
kilograms if you're somewhere else in
the world dimension units i'll just
choose inches
and
you can choose if you want to enable
reviews if you want to enable star
rating i'll just save what we have here
and then you're probably going to want
to go to inventory here too
and so in inventory you can determine
whether you're going to enable stock
management so i can just turn that off
and it won't ever tell how much you have
in stock
or you can set all these things based on
when something is low stock when
something is out of stock you can also
change things for the downloadable
products
and for the downloadable products
you can determine whether you have to re
download you can do downloads require
login
are you going to grant access to
downloadable products after payment
you're likely going to want to say keep
all this as the default settings but you
can change it if you want
now tax
we're going to talk more about tax later
but you can see there's settings for tax
shipping
we're going to set payments for the
store later and then accounts and
privacy
do you want to allow customers to place
order without an account probably you
want to give customers
as much
freedom and flexibility as possible so
they'll be more likely to go through and
buy products
allow i'm going to allow customers to
create an account while customers create
an account on my account page we want
them to be
just do as much as they possibly can
yeah we want them to log into an
existing encounter and check out if they
have an account
and then here it's going to
link to the privacy policy which we are
going to be able to create later
and then let's go to emails whoops uh
i've got to have to remember to save
this
so here are where you can see the emails
that are sent out
when someone makes an order and you can
update what emails are sent out based on
different things happening in your store
and the rest of this we won't do
anything with so let's go back to our
dashboard
now i'm going to teach you how to
customize your site so it's specific to
your brand so i'm going to go back into
visit site
and i'm going to show you how to
customize every part of this site and
then afterwards i'll show you how to add
your custom items while we're
customizing the site we're just going to
use all the sample items and sample data
that's already there but then afterwards
we'll delete all the sample data so we
can start adding your real products so
if you remember we installed the
elementor page builder that's what i'm
going to show you how to use now so in
this top bar when i click edit with
elementor
and if you get this depending on how you
set up your site you may have to
recreate the kit so we'll do that now
we're going to recreate the kit and then
save changes
you may not even have to do that step
but now let me go back to the site
and then edit with elementor
there's always new versions of elementor
so you may get something telling about
some new version of elementor but
you can just click through that got it
so now we can see the site and then over
on the left side are all the different
elements we can edit with
but look what we can do but we can
actually click any of these elements and
start editing so it says brand new
collection well i can actually just
select this and then i'm going to type
in
robot clothes
are
fun
and you can put anything you want here
your store slogan here this is just for
fun i'm just kind of giving you an
example here but you can change what
this looks like i can go to style
so i can actually change the color if i
want to change it to a specific color
or even better if you don't want to
instead of just picking any color
it's better if your site has specific
colors you don't want to use tons of
colors everywhere you want to stick to
just a few colors on your whole site so
that's easy to do by i can click one of
these global colors i'm going to do
theme color 4 but later i'll show you
how to change those theme colors so when
you change the theme colors then all the
places like for instance one of the
theme colors is red and if i change the
theme color to a different color all the
red will change to a different color but
for now i'm going to continue doing some
edits on here so here is where you can
change uh the the font size uh weight
and all this stuff you can change the
style like if it's bold or italicized
i'm actually going to change this to
normal
and then i'm going to make this a little
smaller because i want this to just be
on two lines and you can even change
like the line height how much space is
between the lines letter spacing
and there's just a lot of different
settings you can you can change to make
it so it works for your specific brand
you can even add a text shadow so that's
i'm going to try adding a shadow here
and we can kind of change where the
shadow is going to be
and you don't have to add shadows just
some some interesting things to make it
stand out and make it specific to your
your store so i'm going to go to
advanced here and this is where you can
change different margins so margin is
going to be so margin and padding are
both going to have to do with how much
space are around the words
so i'm going to change the the margin on
the side
and you can see it's all going together
because it's locked but if we unlink the
values then we can just change one or
you don't have to change them all at the
same time so i can put this back to zero
this can be zero and then we can just
change the left margin to go to the side
and it's going to work the same with
padding so if i unlink this i can change
the padding on the left side
and then there's all these other things
you can do that to the text like any of
this stuff here you can do to any text
on the whole page
so you we can make an interes animation
so it fades in so as soon as you scroll
down to see these words the text can
fade in and there's all these different
options we can make it bounce in
we can make it slide to the left
and
you're probably not going to do that for
your main title but this is just an
example because you can go through in
every text like this new arrivals you
can make it slide in as soon as the
person scrolls down
so you can just experiment with all
these different settings you can like
for instance you can change the
background
so you we can put an image in the
background or we can do a specific color
so i can make it a red background
i'll clear that though or you can
actually put an image in the background
like for instance over here we have a
background image and i'll show you how
to change that for a little bit so
there's these all these different things
to
basically customize it to be exactly how
you want it
so here you can see these three
different things with three different
icons well instead of a check mark i
want to change this icon i'm gonna go to
the icon library
and i can change this i can let's see
where's the search here
obviously i'm going to choose a robot
for the icon because this is all about
robot clothes and i can change this
and i can do the same thing for all of
these icons
now i'm going to show you some settings
that change
stuff on your whole site so if i click
the this hamburger menu i can go to site
settings
so here you can change things that's
that are going to impact things all over
your site now depending on what your
theme is
it may not change things because you may
have a theme that overrides some of
these settings but some things are
pretty important like the site identity
let's go to site identity i'm going to
change this site name will show up in in
the top bar of your website so instead
of my url here i'm going to be call
robot attire and then a site description
this is something that could show up on
some search engines and then some other
places so instead of putting just
another wordpress site i'm going to say
best place
best store for robot attire
and then
logo
this is where we can change our logo
so to switch the logo on the site we're
just going to click here to choose image
first you have to have your logo made i
would recommend a site like fiverr.com
where you can hire someone to make a a
logo for you for five dollars i've
actually used that for some other sites
that i've created but also sometimes i
just create my own logos in this case
i've already created a logo so i'm going
to just go to choose image and i'm going
to upload it and i'm going to select it
and it's uploading and i will
i'll just put logo
and then here's where you can also add a
favicon that's the icon that will appear
on the tab on your browser
so you can choose an icon there's plenty
of websites that you can go to that you
can
upload a picture and it will it will
give you a favicon file that you can
upload right into here
so what i'm going to do is update the
site settings and hopefully we'll see it
right on here
now we can see that the logo didn't
change in wordpress because of how the
page builder works together with the
theme works together with just the
standard wordpress design
there could be multiple places to change
different things
and depending on what theme you're using
the only way to find out for sure how to
change things is through trial and error
so we can see that changing the site
logo here to not change the logo there's
one other place we can change and when
we go to this other place there's
actually quite a few other things we can
change there so let me show you how to
get to there so what we're going to do
is just close this
and then i'm going to click the little
hamburger menu and then click exit to
dashboard
and then we just need to go to this the
wordpress logo here
and now we go to appearance and under
appearance i'm going to go to customize
this is going to enable a whole new
section of of things that we can
customize
so i'm going to go to the header because
we're changing the header here and then
you can see it's showing different
things we have here uh so ht when it
says the top row that's this row up here
this is the top row where it says don't
miss our holiday offer 20 off and then
it has the the social media things and
then we have the main row here which so
it says logo and then it has the menu it
has the search account card that's the
search account card over here so i'm
just going to click where it says menu
now you can see the logo here this is
the old logo i'm going to click this
edit button and then i can just choose
the new logo
okay now we see the new logo right up
here and there's different settings you
can do we can change the the height of
the logo
it's a little too big
and
uh you can change how it's aligned now
while we're on this page let me show you
what some of the other things you can do
okay so let's now change this top bar
here so or one thing i want to do is
change the social media so if i click
social media here here's where we can
add what social media we want to add
like we may not want to we may not want
to have a phone number we probably won't
have an email so i'm just going to have
i'm just going to have twitter and
facebook
and then it you can see they go away
here so now we only have the two links
here and then it says configure the
social links and general layout social
network accounts so let me show you how
to do that we're going to go back here
general
and then social network accounts
and there's all these you can just add
what what your social network account is
here
so for email i'll just put my email
address and then we can go back to the
other one which is the twitter
and you can add and i'll just put
https
colon slash twitter.com
beaucarns but you may have a social
media account directly for your your
store and then here's some other things
we can do
i am going to
go back here and this is a pretty
important thing here if i go to
where's oh i need to go back again
and i'm going to go to colors
this is where you can change the colors
throughout your whole store now i
decided to go ahead and use the red
that's why i made the logo red there but
if you don't want see all these buttons
that are red
if if i go into this color palette or
actually not there if i just actually
click
this color color one
i can change this to blue
and see every place on the site that was
red
is now blue
see and then you can change see that red
there well let's go to color two i think
that could be the hover color let's find
out if i change the green let's see what
happens now if i hover
now it's going to hover as green
and see where this gray here that kind
of looks like this let's see if i change
this what happens if i change this to
red
oh no but i did change this text down
here we'll keep that
and see even this becomes blue here but
since i have the red as the logo i'm
going to change the main color back to
red but you can change the colors for
your
website to match whatever you have as
your logo
and then you can see you can change the
color of different things here the
different headings
what color the links are going to be
but i'm going to go back over here
so here you can change the header and
the footer and stuff like that but to
really change the header you can't just
click here and change the header because
if i click on menu here
it's not going to change the menu items
so if i want to change the menu items in
the header there's somewhere else i have
to do i have to go to do that so let me
click
publish so we publish with our new color
and the logo here
and then i'm going to hit x to go out of
this and go back over here now if i go
to
appearance
menus
this is where we can choose what things
show up in the menu we're not going to
show services so i'm going to
remove services i'm going to remove
news and we're just going to have the
products the home
products about us and contact so the
real thing that a lot of you care about
is the shop page let's just quickly show
it how to edit the about us page in the
contact page and then we will go to the
shop page
so i'm going to go back to visiting the
site
and i'll
never go to about us
now here on the about us page you can
just edit it just like we had at the
other page so i'm going to edit with
elementor
and i'm just going to delete this entire
section here i'm just going to hit the x
bar here
and you can see
there this
top section is is really big that now
that i deleted that little section this
this about us thing there's a lot of
space down here so i'm going to go here
to this edit section
we'll go to style
actually we'll go to advanced and you
can see the padding the padding is why
there's so much blank space here i'm
just gonna change this to zero so zero
zero
and then we can have teams you can
change these pictures you can change
this text to your team names you can
just update and remove things just like
we did on the other page
okay let's go to the contact page
oh and before i forget when you make
changes it doesn't actually make the
changes until you click update so i'm
going to click the update down here and
then we'll go to the contact page so
here's our contact form now you can edit
with elementor just like we've seen but
let me show you how you would actually
edit what fields are in this form i'm
going to go up to wp forms right here
and i'm going to simple contact form
edit form
now i can add things to remove things
like phone we don't need to know the
person's phone number
okay we do need want to know the email
address and i can get something new like
i may want to use some check boxes so
i'm going to click this check box and
drag it over here
and then i can edit it so
reason for contact
website
question
sales
want a
cookie now i can save that
but before i go back to my contact page
i'm going to settings and notifications
and make sure this is on sometimes
you'll be off you want to make sure
these notifications are on
and this is going to send to your admin
email address
so i'm going to
save this
it will access
now i'll go back to my contact page and
we'll try it out
[Music]
and i do want a cookie
hello now click send message
now i'll go to my email address this is
the info robot attire.com which is my
current admin email going here and here
want a cookie hello i got the email
well that works
let's check out this header there's
still some menu items that i thought
were removed so let me go back over to
the dashboard
appearance menus
and i did not save the menu last time
that was the problem
so
let me
remove this
remove that
and then we'll save the menu
and this time it will hopefully work
okay that looks good
okay we finally reached the part you've
been waiting for
the product
page so let me show you how you can
change the product page now you can see
there is no edit with elementor up here
so we can only click customize
now i'm going to scroll down here
to where it says woocommerce
the product page is through woocommerce
so here we can change things like see
how there's three columns here well what
i can add additional columns of products
i can do two columns
and then we can change how many
rows right now there are four rows we
may want to only have three rows
you can also
change if it's going what type of the
shop is going to look like
there's some just some minor differences
between each of these styles
and we can change how it's going to sort
what kind of sidebar we're going to have
so right now we have the the filter we
can we can filter so we can just show
the products or we can turn back on the
sidebar where we can filter by different
but in different ways
so you can go through here and change
things i'm going to turn off this page
title so when you click pro products
it's going to go right to the store page
right here
and another thing we're going you can do
from here
is change what a single product page
looks like so let me go into this black
t-shirt product page
and we can change what this product page
looks like so here's some things we can
so see what the top rated products is on
one side we can
click here to make it switch sides maybe
we don't want that top rated products we
can turn that off
by clicking the narrow width i'm going
to go back to the the right sidebar one
and then sail badge so see how it says
sale up there we can turn that off
and turn it back on we can choose
whether it's going to show the star
rating the metadata
you can go to product gallery
and i can change see how it zooms when i
go over it well i can turn that off
so now when i scroll over it's not going
to zoom into the product so you can play
around with these settings until you get
your product page looking exactly how
you want to look how you want to look
okay and when you're editing a product
page let me show you how you would edit
these the sidebar here and then also the
reviews well the reviews i already
actually showed you a while back how to
turn on and off reviews that's in the
woocommerce settings
so you can
say you can turn off reviews for
everything or turn on reviews for
everything right now they're turned on
let me show you how you would update
this sidebar right here
because i don't really like this black
box right here i do kind of like the
related products but i don't like this
new cloth technologies box
so to do that i'm going to have to go
to the this main wordpress press
dashboard i'm going to go to appearance
and widgets that sidebar is under
widgets so
the specific widget is actually this
woocommerce
sidebar and we have the top rated
project products that we saw in here and
then we had
this whole thing right here so i'm just
going to click this and then click
delete
so now
we're only going to have the top rated
products and see when i click into top
rated products you can choose what the
title of this is going to be how many
products to show and stuff like that and
also i'm going to go up here and i'm
also going to delete this in the main
sidebar i'm going to delete this black
thing right here and then you can add
anything else you want to the sidebar
and then i'm going to click update
now we can go back over to that oh
really quick i'll show you one more time
how you would turn off the the comments
if you go to woocommerce settings here
and then you go to
products and then you can disable the in
the enable product reviews you can turn
off
okay we'll just go
back to here visit site
now if we go back to our product page
now we don't have that black thing right
there another thing we can do
is change what the shopping cart looks
like so i'm going to click the shopping
cart right here
so we can go to the checkout page and
they can click proceed to checkout here
and now we can we can change what the
checkout page looks like like for
instance
i can turn on the coupon form
and now
people can choose if they have a coupon
they can put do click here to enter the
code
and then we can check like what's going
to be required here and you can you can
also choose what what's going to show up
about your privacy policy and this is a
link to the privacy policy page which we
still have to edit i'm actually going to
open up this into a new tab really quick
so i can so we can show you how to edit
the privacy policy
so to edit this privacy policy
i'm going to go back into the main
wordpress menu
i'm going to go to pages
and then i'm going to find the privacy
policy page
i'm going to edit this
and now we can edit the privacy policy
i'm just going to use all the suggested
text
so i'm just going to delete where it
says suggested text
and then i can click publish
okay now i want to make sure i'm using
this right privacy policy my and my
checkout page let's go back to the
checkout page and
there's a few privacy i'm going to
choose this first privacy policy
and then we'll just click it to make
sure it's the right one
okay that's the right one and then make
sure you click publish here so any
changes you always want to click publish
to make sure all the changes happen the
ecommerce site is starting to look
pretty good now let's see how to add
products to the store so in order to add
some custom products we're going to go
back to the main
the main dashboard
and i'm going to click where it says
products here
before i do this see it keeps saying it
keeps suggesting that we connect monster
insights to set up website analytics now
if we click here it's going to go it's
going to actually walk us through all
the steps that's outside the scope of
this particular tutorial so i should
have done this earlier but what i'm
going to do is is
delete this plug-in so we don't have to
keep seeing it we're going to plug-ins
so before we can delete a pro plug-in
you have to deactivate it so i'm going
to deactivate this plug-in
and then i am going to
check it
and then i'm going to just click delete
and then if i refresh this page
oh and to get i guess there's one more
thing we have to remove let's deactivate
this
and then delete it
now it's no longer showing that message
good so let's go back to the products
again
the first thing we're going to do
is just remove all the products that are
currently there
so i'm just going to click this
and then we are going to
move to trash
and click apply
okay
now we can just start adding some
products from scratch
so the first type of product i'm going
to teach you how to create is a simple
product
so this is a simple product it has a
picture sometimes there can be
additional pictures below we only have
one picture for this one it has a title
it has a description and then down here
it's going to have a more detailed
description so let me show you how you
create a product like this it's simple
because there are no options that you
would have to choose
so let's go back to the main dashboard
so i'm going to click add new to add a
new product
robot
hat
and then we can add the description
so this description
is the description that appears second
on the page that will just contain
additional information about the product
because the user will have already read
a description and so this could be like
made in the usa
you will not want to return this
and then if we scroll down here to this
other description this is the
description that the customer will see
first the short description
so
i'm just going to paste in a description
for the robot hat now i'm going to go
back up here and make sure we have
simple product chosen here it's not
virtual or downloadable but we could
make a downloadable product
and then we can put the full price but
50
and then we can put the sales price we
can also schedule how long the sale is
going to happen for so i can say that
it's going to start today and it's going
to go for a week so then after that time
is up it won't show that sales price
anymore so let's go to inventory you can
have a skewed number if you have a
specific number for the product and then
there's also managed stock
so if you have managed stock you'll keep
track of how much you have in stock so i
can say 10
and then if you have a stock on the
product page will actually tell how many
are left in stock
and then do you want to
allow people to to purchase it after
it's not in stock and create a back
order and then you can also choose if
you want to be sold individually
and then you can put information about
the shipping like the weight the
dimensions
and then you can choose a shipping class
which we don't have any setup right now
also you can choose linked products now
remember on the product page where there
was some products on the side there's
products on the bottom this is where you
set those products now i don't actually
this is the first product i'm creating
so i don't have any to add but once you
add a bunch of products you can select
which things are going to be considered
upsells and which things are going to be
considered cross cells so it will
suggest the other products to users at
various times and then we have
attributes which we will talk more later
when we get to some of these other types
of products
and then advance a purchase note is a
note that will be sent to the the
customer after they purchase it now menu
order this changes how far up on your
page will show so when you have a bunch
of different
products on your page
the lower this number the higher it
appears on the page so
the the the products you want to show to
the user the most you want to have a
lower number and we have the reviews
enabled for all the products but you can
turn off reviews for individual products
here
and then we already talked about this
description
okay the next thing we're going to do is
add the product image so i'll go up here
set a product image
and i'm going to upload a file
and here's my product image this robot
hat and then if you have other images
that won't be the main image you can add
them here the product gallery images
product tags you want to give similar
items the same tag like i'll add hat for
this and then if we add any other hat
we'll use the same tag and then people
can click the word hat and they can see
all the hats
and then we're also going to add this to
the accessories category no another
thing to just have all the accessories
in the category all t-shirts in the same
category
and so on
now i kind of skipped over this before
but this gives you information about seo
and you can change the different
descriptions and titles and and try to
adjust the snippets are going to appear
on so on search engines and other places
on the web but we're not going to go
into that right now right now i'm just
gonna go and click publish and we've now
created a simple product
our product is created so let's check it
out so it says we can click on view
product right here and it'll open up the
product page
so here's the hat here we got the title
we put in it shows it's on sale here's
the description and we have a 10 in
stock
and then it shows our category and our
tags here if we click accessory we can
see all the accessories currently
there's no other accessories
but we can go back to the product page
and then you can see here's the
additional description here
and
here's the reviews i can even leave a
review right now
best hat ever
and then i click submit and right now
i'm logged in i'll show the account that
i'm logged in at so that your users will
be able to create their own account on
the store and then they will be able to
to leave reviews
so we have our simple product now we're
going to create a variable product a
variable product is just a product where
you can change the options you can maybe
change the color or change the size but
like do you want a medium size a large
size a small size blue red so let me
show you how to create a variable
product we could go back to the product
page but even right on this page there's
a pl there's a new thing we can click on
new and then product so we're creating a
new product right now and i'm going to
call this a robot shirt
we're going to have different colors and
different sizes of shirts
so to create a variable or product we'll
put in the description um made in
your country
and we're gonna go down and we can just
put the the full description
okay we've got the description so now
we're going to click it says symbol
program and click this and go to
variable product
so some of this is going to be the same
but now we are going to have attributes
and variations so let's go to the
attributes and i'm going to
add an attribute the first is going to
be size
and then it says right here enter some
text and it shows to use this to
separate the attributes this is not an
eye it's actually a vertical bar it's on
your keyboard right on the same key as
the backslash so i'm going to put
small
medium
large
okay i'll save the attribute
and then i'm going to add another one
which is going to be
color
and we'll do
red
and blue
and i'll save this
okay so now
a customer will be able to choose the
size and the color of the shirt okay so
now i'm going to save the attributes
we'll go to variations and it says you
need to add some variations on the
attributes tab
that's because we need to go back to the
attributes and there's one thing we
forgot which is to click this button
says that says use for variations
and for color let me put that down use
for variations we'll just save that now
we'll go back to variations and at this
point we can click at this drop down
menu and create variations from all
attributes
and then it'll say are you sure you want
to do this yes we want to do that
and it's added six variations
okay so it's added for every
it's added every size and every color
now here is where it gets kind of
tedious we're going to have to add
information for every single
variation
so
we are going so all these options are
very similar to the the simple product
options and we're going to have to add
these for every variation so
for price for the small it's going to be
20
in stock you can add weights if you want
if we go up here and click this image we
can upload an image now i'm going to
upload a few files here
and i'm uploading a blue shirt a picture
of a blue shirt and a picture of a red
shirt
and then i'll set this as the variation
so for the small red shirt we're going
to show the the red shirt here
and then we have to go through for all
these other ones so for the small blue
shirt i'm going to add the blue shirt
here
and it's going to be
20
and then we'll just keep going down here
and for
the medium it's going to be the same i'm
just going to select the same image this
time i'm going to put a different
different price this is going to be 25
the medium will be 25 this is just just
to show an example that you can use
different prices and
even different sales prices for
different uh different variations i'll
make the sale price so this registers on
sale so i'll make this uh 20. let's say
you have more of that type of shirt that
you just need to get rid of
and then we'll just go through and set
the rest of these
okay after we set all these variations
i'm going to save changes
and now we can add everything that you
add to the simple product like you we
can add tags i'm going to put
shirt
and then i can also
go to a category select t-search for the
category and then you're still going to
want to select a product image when a
product is initially shown on the store
page
before the customer can choose what type
of color they're looking at it's going
to have to show just a single image so
this is just going to be the initial
image that's going to be shown we'll
show the the blue
and that reminded me one more thing
let's go back over to
uh the variations
you can also set a default size and the
default color to be selected so we're
going to put a default size to medium
and a default color to blue just like
it's showing the blue image
okay now we can go up here and
we can
publish
now let's view the product to see what
this looks like
okay see it's showing it could be
anywhere between 20 and 30 dollars
depending on
which size and which color and you can
see here's the blue one but if i
go to
a large it's gonna it's going to change
the price to 30. if i change the color i
can change it to red it should show the
red shirt and just like before well just
just like before we'll have
reviews there's even additional
information it's going to show the
different sizes possible in the
different colors possible
and you can see automatically is putting
related products up here
so really i don't have there's not
really very many products so it's just
going to show the products that we
already have
now we're going to create a grouped
product a group product is a product
where there's a few different options
and each options come with different
items
like say you're selling a camera and
you'll have a product page for the
camera but you can select just the
camera or you can select the camera in
the bag or you can select the camera bag
and tripod and each group of pro each
group of items under the product page
would have different prices so let's see
how to do that i'm going to go to new
product
so to make a group product we have to
make the main product and then we have
to create all the sub products that are
within the group so since this is a
robot attire store what if we actually
sold an actual robot or a robot toy so
i'm going to put robot
toy
for the main product and then we can
just add the descriptions
okay after we add the descriptions we
can change the product to grouped
product
and then we can add uh
categories so i actually already added a
new category category called robot and
then you can add tags like toy
fun
and then i'll just add those
and then we will add an image so i've
already uploaded this robot picture so
i'll set that as the pro the product
image
and then i will publish it
okay now we have to create the sub
products so i'll click add new and then
i'll put cosmo robot because the robot
toy is gonna be a cosmo robot we already
have the description so we don't need to
add the description all we have to do is
add the price which we'll set as 100
and then what we want to do is make sure
it's invisible so right now this will
just show up on the normal store page
but we want to click the edit for the
catalog visibility and we'll have it
hidden so we'll only show up as the
grouped product so i'll publish this
and now i'll create two more so let me
just copy this and i'll do add new
so this is going to be ro cosmo robot
plus
case
and then this is just going to be 150
and then we will
put the visibility to hidden
and then i'll just do one final product
which will be cosmo robot plus case plus
extra charger
then this will be two hundred dollars
and then i will
again change the visibility and publish
now that we have all these sub products
created let's go back to our main
product page and i will select the robot
toy the initial one and click edit now
we'll go down and go to linked products
and here's where we add all the linked
products so we have casual robot
we have cosmo robot plus case
and we have cosmo robot plus case plus
extra charger
then i'll just update this product
and now we can view product to see what
it looks like
okay so we have it says robot toy and we
can choose cosmo robot plasma robot plus
case or cosmonaut robot plus case was
extra charger and you can see it has the
price range of all these prices and
everything else is basically the same as
the other types of products
okay we're going to learn about one
final type of product which is a
downloadable product so i'm going to new
and click on product so a downloadable
product could be an e-book it could be
an image it could be a zip file full of
a bunch of different files and it could
be a song maybe
so we are going to actually be selling a
song a robot song
and
uh and we just add the descriptions just
like all the other products
okay now we can change from it's going
to be a simple product but we're going
to click virtual and downloadable so
virtual means that it's not going to be
shipped to anybody and downloadable
means we can choose what the file is to
download so this is going to be a three
dollar song
and then i can add the file that's going
to be
downloaded so i'm going to go to choose
file
and then i'll upload the file
and then i go have this robotsong.mp3
and i don't know why i added all these
extra characters at the end because that
wasn't on my computer but no problem
so now it actually puts the url right in
here and then for the file name i'm
going to put
robotsong.mp3
and then you can choose how many times
the person can download it it's default
to unlimited but maybe you only want
someone to be able to download it three
times and then how long will the
download link work so right now it will
work forever but we can make the
download link expire after a certain
number of days let's give them one week
to download the song
okay we'll go up here and just add i'm
going to add make this an accessory we
could make a new category called the
songs and then for
tags we'll just put song
and then oh yeah also we're going to
need a picture so i'm going to set the
product image
instead of uploading a new image i'm
just going to pick one that's already in
here so
this looks like
so how about this one see this person's
actually listening to something so we'll
set that as the product image because
they're they're listening to the song
right in there so now i'm going to
publish this
and we'll go to view product
okay so if you add this to car and
actually go to the checkout it will end
up giving you a link to download the
song
our store is products now it's time to
make it so a customer can actually check
out by configuring payment processing
taxes shipping coupons and more okay now
we're going to add payments we're going
to make it so your store can accept
credit cards and to do that we're going
to add a new plugins let's go to the
plugins here
the way we're going to make it so
customers can pay with a credit card is
through stripe
and to do that we're going to add a new
plugin so i'll click add new
and now i'm going to search for stripe
and then we have the woocommerce stripe
payment gateway so i'll just install
that
okay then i'll activate
now let's create or log into our stripe
account
okay i'm here at stripe.com and i'm
going to click sign in and you click
that whether you have an account yet or
not
and then i'm going to you can either
sign with your account or you can sign
up
if this is your first time creating an
account you're going to have to verify a
link in your email
the great thing about stripe is it's
completely free to use
now i'll go to payments
and these are all the different things
you can set up as payments and i'm going
to turn stripe on
and then we can connect or create a
stripe account to accept payments so i'm
going to click here connect or create a
connect account we already created the
account
and then i'm just going to go through
this they just want to verify my phone
number so i'll enter my phone number
here
and now we'll connect the account
and now we'll just put information about
the business like address and other
things
and then you can even put your bank
account information so you can get your
payout from stripe
okay we got done i got done putting in
all the really personal information to
get this stripe
account set up and connected
now we're going to update what shows up
on your store website when someone's
paying by stripe instead of credit card
stripe let's just call it credit card
people don't necessarily have to know
that it's using stripe
and luckily the the keys from the stripe
account automatically got uh switched
over here
okay now we have to we have a few things
disabled that way to fix so it says that
the payments payouts is disabled until
missing business information is updated
it's going to go here
edit account keys
and we have to add this url to the
stripe account settings so i'll copy
that
add endpoint
and add the endpoint
we're just going to listen for all
endpoints i'll click add events
and then add endpoint
and now i just have to copy this web
hook hook secret
and go back to woocommerce and i'm just
going to paste in right here
and then save live keys
okay we can now accept payments
we can accept payments we can't do
payouts yet
until we put in a little information a
little more information on the stripe
page
but we can receive the payments and then
once we update more information about
like our bank account and stuff like
that then we can accept the payouts
so on stripe if you want to test it out
you can enable test mode here and then
when you're done testing it make sure
you turn test mode off and uh stripe
gives you some test card numbers so if i
click here it's going to open up these
test card numbers that you can use so
when you're testing your website you can
use these test numbers they're not real
numbers but stripe you can use this to
test an order with stripe
okay let's go back over here we're going
to set up one more method of payment so
i'm going to click payment here
and now i'm going to set up payment with
paypal so you can set up any of these
types of payments and if no matter which
one you pick it's going to walk you
through that but for this tutorial i'm
just showing stripe and paypal so i'm
going to install another plugin so i'm
going to click on plugins here
and then i'm just going to search for uh
or actually i'm going to click add new
and then i'm going to search for paypal
[Music]
okay woocommerce paypal payments install
now
and activate
okay now i can just go to woocommerce
settings
and then payments
and then i can come down to where it
says paypal
turn that on
and then i'm going to connect to paypal
just like with stripe you're going to
create a paypal account or maybe you
already have one i'm just going to sign
into my paypal account that i already
have
and you'll have to make sure it's a
paypal business account so i'm going to
create a new business account
you're going to set up a paypal business
account but after you do all that you
can go back to
wordpress
and then we're going to enable the
paypal gateway
so you can kind of change what it's
going to look like
but most of this you can kind of just
keep the default settings
the only thing you may want to do is
decide whether you're going to use
sandbox mode to test it
or you want to actually turn it on for
real so we'll leave sandbox mode off so
we'll have it turned on for real and
then i'll just save changes
okay now we have two forms of payment
set up stripe for credit cards and then
we also have paypal
we're going to test it all out in a
moment
but first
let's set up the tax
so to get taxes to work we have this tax
tab here
but to make it even easier we're gonna
we're gonna install another plugin so
i'm gonna go down to plugins again
and this time i'm just going to go
directly to add new plugin
and i'm going to search for
tax
[Music]
and then we're going to look for
woocommerce shipping and tax
so this is going to make it much easier
to set up both the shipping and tax
that's the great thing about wordpress
is that there's plugins for basically
anything to help make different things
easier
okay now i'm going to activate it
and now it's going to say it's going to
tell me to install jetpack and connect
so to make this easy tax system work
you're going to have to install jetpack
another thing and also create a jetpack
account but it's going to make things
way easier to se than to set up
taxes manually for every state
installation failed destination folder
already exists this could mean that it
tried to install and something messed up
in the installation and then when it
tried to install again the folder was
already there so to actually to remove
that the folder we're actually going to
go back to hostinger and we're going to
have to go to our hosting account for
robot attire
so let me go to manage
and now i'm going to have to go to where
we can actually to access the actual
files that make up wordpress and be able
to find that folder and delete so let me
scroll down a little bit here
and i'm going to go to file manager
now you have to be very careful when
you're in the file manager because if
you've messed some up something here it
can mess up a lot of things on your
website
i'm going to open this
okay now i define wp content
now plugins
and now i'm going to find
jetpack
and i'm just going to
delete this jetpack folder by clicking
the delete button up here
okay now that jetpack is deleted we can
go back to our hosting our page
and
i'm just going to refresh this so we can
try
installing jetpack again so i'm going to
click install now
okay since all i can just activate this
now
now i have to set it up so set up
jetpack
like i said i'm going to have to create
an account
i'm just going to create an account with
my google login
and we can choose any of these paid
plans but if we scroll down a little bit
we can just do jetpack free so we're
just going to use the free version
and then you just set the
do some things here and then
make sure to not choose anything that
costs money
i'm just going to click dot not now for
all these things
okay this is set up we don't actually
have to get this this plan here so i'm
going to go back to woocommerce and back
to settings
now to tax
okay now we have the option to enable
automated taxes
this is going to make everything work
way easier if you don't have automated
taxes you have to set up the taxes
individually for each state and each
place that you're shipping to or
shipping from but automated taxes will
just figure that out all on on its own
it will be see it says your tax rate and
sex will be automatically configured for
michigan united states that's where i
live if you live somewhere else it will
just enable it will just automatically
figure out the taxes from where you're
shipping from
and we're we're enabling prices
exclusive attack so the tax will be
added
extra and then we're going to calculate
tax based on customer shipping address
most of this you're just going to use
exactly how it's set so i'm just going
to click save changes
okay now we can do something similar
with shipping i'm going to go to
shipping
so we're going to create some shipping
zones it says right here shipping zone
is a geographic region where a certain
set of shipping methods and rates apply
and we're going to add a shipping zone
and then you're going to choose where
the zone so let's make a zipping
shipping zone called
united
states
and then i'll and i'm going to
ship
and i'm going to choose united
states so for the entire united states
we're going to add certain shipping
methods so the first one so we have a
few options we have the flat rate free
shipping or local pickup so i'm going to
click add shipping method
for a flat rate
now i can edit this so
some places
depending on where you're located
sometimes uh shipping will be taxable in
a lot of places it's not so i'm gonna
click none but you'll you're gonna have
to look at your area wherever you're
based off of out of to see if you should
tax the shipping or not so i'm gonna put
a flat rate of just how about six
dollars and i'll save the changes now we
can add another shipping method so let's
say we want free shipping but we only
want free shipping if someone spends
enough money so i'm gonna go to edit and
free shipping requires what does it
require well uh maybe a shipping coupon
we'll talk about coupons a little bit
here or maybe a minimum order amount you
can see there's different options i'm
gonna do a minimum order amount so i'm
gonna make someone spend at least
thirty dollars to get free shipping
when do coupons apply are we going to
apply minimum order rule before the
coupon discount or after the coupon
discount um we'll just do after the
coupon discount and then click save
changes so now people have the option of
the flat rate or the free shipping
so we added this shipping zone we're
also going to add another shipping zone
so i'm going to click shipping zone here
and then we have united states but let's
say we want to
ship to another country like maybe we
want to ship to
canada
so the shipping is going to cost a
little more since i'm based in the
united states and i'll do all of canada
and here we're going to do flat rate and
it's going to be
this time
ten dollars it's a little more because
we have to ship it a little further
and then i can go back to shipping zone
and then you can see you can also do
local pickup if you want to add your
specific city or state
and then you can choose local pickup
okay let's look at some of these options
here
so you can choose whether you want to
hide the shipping cost until an address
entered or just depending on what you
want to look like to the customer
now shipping classes allows you to
create different shipping costs for
different types of products
so maybe some products you'll be
charging five dollars for shipping some
products you'll be charging ten dollars
for shipping i'm not going to show you
this in this tutorial but you can add
different shipping classes and then set
your products to to go with that
shipping class and then that product
will
will
be charged that shipping rate but let's
go to this next tab here woocommerce
shipping
and this is because we have
the plug-in installed we have the
woocommerce shipping plug-in and it
allows us to automatically print
shipping labels and save a trip to the
post office so you can choose some
settings like
where how are you going to print the
labels
and then if you want to be able to
purchase shipping labels right through
here
and so i'm just going to leave this all
as it is
okay now we're going to learn about
creating coupon codes it's actually
pretty simple so on the woocommerce area
here and click on coupons
it's telling us actually in this new
version the coupon management has moved
so let's remove the legacy coupon menu
so we'll just be using the new coupon
menu which is now in marketing coupons
and i'll just we can either click on
create your first coupon or just add
coupon i'll click on add coupon because
this is the method that you're going to
be using the most and then we can just
create the coupon code and i'm going to
create the code
robots are amazing
this description is really just for you
and i'll put robot coupon
and then there's a few different types
of coupons you can make you can make a
percentage discount so everything's
going to be 10 off a fixed cart discount
so you get 5 off your order or a fixed
product discount which is a discount
that only applies to one specific
product
so what i'm going to do is create a
percentage discount so we can put 10
percent
and then you can choose whether you want
to always allow free shipping or maybe
maybe don't so the coupon can include
free shipping or it cannot and then you
can choose when it expires so let's say
it expires here a week later and then we
can go over to uh usage restrictions so
how much do they have to spend to be
able to use the coupon so let's say they
have to spend twenty dollars to use the
coupon and what's the maximum number uh
you may have no maximum but maybe you
don't want them to be able to use a
coupon on an order that's over five
hundred dollars
and then you can choose whether the
coupon can be used with other coupons or
not whether it should exclude sale items
and then here is where you would choose
if a coupon applied only to a specific
product or if a product would be
excluded from a coupon you know there's
some things that never go on sale like
have you ever seen a nintendo switch on
sale well
they would have that excluded
and then you can apply the coupon only
to specific categories exclude
categories and then if you only want
certain email addresses to be able to
use it so only certain people can use
the coupon you can put it here and then
we have the usage limit so how many
times can this coupon be used well after
500 times the coupon can no longer be
used anymore
so
how many
here's how many items you can use it for
so how many how full your cart can be
and then how many times can each user
use a coupon we'll just put one time
that makes sense each user can only use
the coupon one time obviously someone
could just create a new account and use
it again but that limits it somewhat and
i'm going to
publish this coupon
okay at this point we're gonna test all
this i'm gonna go to the store
and purchase something
and use this coupon so let me go to the
store visit store or visit site or visit
store go to products
and actually i already have two things
in my cart from before oh an item which
is no longer available to move from your
card well i'll remove this too so i can
do the whole thing from the beginning so
let me go to the shop
and
i am going to
get a hat so i just add i just could
click add cart and then here you can't
add to the car because you just select
the options first
so i'm going to get a small shirt that's
the color red
and
i will add this to cart
and so we have this options here where
you can pay without even going to the
cart actually let's turn that off
because we want someone to actually have
to go to the cart before they pay
okay i'm on woocommerce settings i'm on
payments and i'm going to go down to
where it says paypal i'm going to manage
that
and then i'm going to scroll down where
it says single product page and then i'm
going to disable enable on single
product
so now it's not going to show up on the
product page will still show up on the
cart though and i'm going to save
changes
then one more thing i'm going to do i'm
going to go back to the payments tab and
then i'm going to go to the the stripe
payment settings
and we are going to
disable this express checkout
so it's not going to
show these express checkout buttons okay
now let's go back to our product page
okay i'll just refresh the cart page and
you can see those buttons are gone so
i'll add a medium
how about a small red shirt add to cart
okay now i'm going to view the cart
okay these two cards i thought i added a
hat
let me go back and add a hat really
quick
and add to cart okay now i'll view the
cart
okay so now i have two shirts and a hat
now i'm going to a plo apply a coupon so
robots are
amazing
apply the coupon
okay now you can see that we've got a
nine dollar discount
and i can choose between
flat rate or free shipping because
remember we set free shipping as long as
the the amount is over fifty dollars
it's showing that shipping to michigan
and then i'll proceed to checkout okay
now i can put in some of my information
here then i'm going to put in a demo
credit card number from stripe
and then here i don't think the
numbers here matter when i'm using the
demo
oh yeah i had to be in in test mode to
test the cart so let me go back over to
this menu i'm going to quickly go to
manage stripe
and then
enable test mode
okay let me save that and then i have to
when i'm in test mode you have to have
special test keys so go to edit account
keys
oh see there's the live keys and there's
the test keys
so let me get the
publishable key
and then the test secret key
and then the test secret web hook
so we're setting this up just like
before
and i'm going to add the endpoint and
then i just need to copy this id
put it in here
and save test keys
okay i'm going to refresh the page
put in the billing information and then
i'll put in this test credit card
information
and then place order
and thank you your order has been
received
now let's go look at our administrator
email account so here's the
administrator email account so we get an
email when we receive an order and it's
showing new order you've received an
order from oh carns and it has all the
information it has the shipping address
now let's go to our administrator
dashboard
now if we go to orders here
we can see the order it says order from
both cards is processing
so three items are ready to be fulfilled
i could create the shipping label send
the product and go from processing to
completed and then i'm going to update
that
and then in this customers tab we can
now see the customer there's a new
customer
and then we can go to
the reports tab uh showing how much
we've how much money we've made and then
the orders tab we still have that order
in there finally we are going to talk
about the emails that get sent to the
customers
so i'm gonna go to settings and then
emails so here you can check the emails
that get sent for various reasons so we
already have the emails go to the
administrator email for new order
canceled order failed order
but then an email would get sent to
customers for all these other things
such as a completed order processing
order and if you click on manage you can
choose what the email is going to look
like you can enable or disable the email
notification you can change the subject
email heading additional content so you
can choose what email that you the
customer is going to get and one thing
to
notice if i go back to the email tab
here it has this message here so in case
if you get this all set up and the email
does not arrive to the customer you're
gonna have to look at this here to
ensure your store's notifications arrive
in your and your customers inboxes we
recommend connecting your email address
to your domain and setting up a
dedicated smtp server if something
doesn't seem to be seen correctly
install the wp mail logging plugin
so
it could just work out of the box but if
it doesn't i would recommend installing
this plugin and it's pretty
straightforward i'm not going to show in
this tutorial but i'll just take you
step by step into getting it working and
then that will make it more likely that
your email will get to your customer
okay we're almost done there is one more
loose end i want to cover which is this
top bar here where it has don't miss our
holiday offer 20 off well we probably
don't want that because it may not be a
holiday
so i'm gonna go to customize
and then i'm gonna go to header
and here's the top row so if you
remember there was the social icons on
the right side and then we have the
message on this side so i'm going to
click here
and now here we can change what message
is in this
top row here
so maybe instead of there the holiday
instead of talking about the holiday
offer we can say
check out our new
hats
and then you can actually make this a
link and you can link it to your hat
page
so
i'm just gonna whoops uh yeah publish
this
another thing i could do is just remove
this completely so if i just hit x on
socials
and x on top row or x on this html thing
and i publish it
now if i go to my website i'll just x
out of this
now we don't even have that row at the
top so you may just not even want that
top bar
the store is complete you now know how
to set up a fully functioning ecommerce
website there are a ton of settings and
plug-ins that we didn't even get to so
feel free to just explore the different
options and see how you can customize
your store even more good luck with
selling your products